it is 606. you know las vegas is still a
big
home for all those march madness fans
sports books casinos they're going to be
real busy with watch parties all day
long alex
yeah they are hector mejia live inside
the luxor with a family-friendly event
happening there hey hector happy friday
hey there guys happy friday to you guys
so you know a lot of people
obviously looking forward to this since
things were canceled last year and this
morning
we're getting a live look inside the
hyperx esports arena at the luxor
we're on the second floor on the boss
level boss level wide because we're
about to walk into a suite
joining us live we have jim he's going
to talk to us about that massive screen
available for families to watch the
games and so it's a ticketed event
but we were describing it as a family
friendly event because it's open to all
ages
and another thing to note kind of like a
new trend here in town smoke free good
morning to you good morning
yep all ages so if you want to come in
and watch some basketball
we'll also sit in the lobby and play
some minecraft that's absolutely
something you can do at the hyperx
esport arena
unique to any other place in las vegas
and uh we were just talking about this
earlier the ticket basically kind of
pays for itself because it includes a
couple of things yes it includes your
seat
for all day it includes five drink
tickets and then we do have an all
cart menu that you can order off of how
excited are you a lot of people looking
forward to it the parking lot outside
looks like it's jam-packed
yeah the ride of passage is here
everybody's looking for their one shiny
moment
i am so glad that march madness has
returned and
i'm glad to be hosting march mayhem here
at the hyperx esport arena
today we were also talking about um what
were we talking about it just escaped to
my mind oh
yeah we were talking about you guys uh
hosting march madness games for the
first time here at this venue
yes it we had planned on doing it last
year for the first time
the success that we've had with the big
game over the past couple years
has moved us into wanting to host a
march mayhem party here at the hyperx
esport arena
and because of the success and and
everybody moving forward with
the the the precautions and safety and
the the ability to be able to bring
people in is something that
us and here at the hyperx export arena
can are more excited than
to do and lastly on that note uh
assigned seating
socially distanced temperature checks at
the door
uh talk a little bit about the uh
precautions here yeah so we
everybody that will come in will be temp
checked we do have
sanitation stations all around the arena
everybody is socially distanced apart if
you come together you can stay together
but all of the guests will be socially
distanced apart it's kind of cool though
that bruins and bears and bulldogs and
boilermakers all can come in to
conjugate into one place and have a good
time to watch the basketball a place for
everyone thank you very much so we'll be
going over to the stage next so stay
tuned
we'll be back in half an hour for now
reporting live hector mejia
eight news now back to you guys
[Music]